parents at cashman middle school they're
really fed up with drivers in that
general area cashman is on a busy road
it's on desert in near decatur parents
say cars just aren't slowing down
narrowly missing children as they
attempt to go to school kate houston
went to the campus to see the changes
they want made
the crosswalk is extremely dangerous
people don't stop this is a common sight
outside of cashman middle school a
student attempts to cross desert and
road with cars still passing just feet
in front of them that's why i'm out here
with him now because first day cars
didn't stop and after that that was
enough for me you know you can't take
chances like
one time could be that wrong
james beacham walks his son to school
every morning a lot of the parents we
work but you have to come out here you
have to find a way to get out here and
be with your children because if you
don't that street is very dangerous this
crosswalk spans seven lanes despite
flashing lights indicating a school zone
many cars don't slow or stop not even
for this school administrator now
parents are pushing for crossing guards
to be placed outside of the school
saying something bad shouldn't have to
happen before something is done
currently crossing guards are placed at
elementary schools but parents like
carmen martinez say it's necessary at
cashman middle and it actually helps a
lot
a lot with traffic and you know it keeps
up more and more discipline not only the
car that drive the car but like
pedestrians too moving forward beacham
wants to work with other parents to
provide a safer environment for these
students i'd rather something happen
before you know something bad happens
someone gets hurt or let alone killed
nobody wants that to happen kate houston
8 news now
crossing guards are overseen by
municipality not the school district
cashman middle school falls under
unincorporated clark county we have
reached out to the county for more
guidance on this issue and they are
gathering information we are told